hi this is steve kaufman and i'm again
and i'm really pleased to have with me
today as a guest someone that i've known
for a long time at various sort of
meetups of language cleaners ollie
richards of storylearning.com
and uh hello ali hi steve thank you
please allow me to say first of all hi
if people uh enjoy my videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on a
podcast please leave a comment
ali steve uh you and i have been
involved in this whole
kind of internet based language learning
thing for quite a while yes and i want
to go over some of the ways in which
language learning has changed and and of
course both of us started learning
languages long before this whole
internet thing started
how language learning has changed how
the technology has changed how we've had
to change so that's what i would like to
talk about with you if you agree
i am at your service
okay so
before we get going tell me a little bit
about
storylearning.com yeah so story learning
is um
my website it's my youtube channel and
the whole focus of what we do is that we
teach languages through stories and this
all came about
many moons ago
um i mean i've always used stories and
reading as a way to learn languages
but i never really thought about how
i could use it as a teaching vehicle um
but then i had a long career teaching
languages and then i began to actually
write books of short stories which
people really liked and then so i kind
of developed this concept and thought
how many different ways can we teach
people through stories uh much the same
as the mini story that link
but now including a big pedagogical
element as well um and so nowadays
that's that's everything that we do so
we make courses we write books and
everything is about stories
okay
and before we go further into that of
course telling stories in a way our
presence on youtube is a form of
storytelling
we talk about different things we tell
stories
uh i just wanted to i mentioned this to
you before we started up you know here
we are
uh i've been in you know this business
of i mean i guess my first youtube video
was i don't know 15 years i've seen it i
remember it when i was just thinking
yeah
on the chair so so then i was just
thinking here i am you know getting set
up for my interview with you and i
thought i would describe to people what
i have to do so i have my ipad open
because that's where i communicate with
you
and you might describe what you do at
your end but so i i'm no longer looking
at you even though you are there and i
hear you through my
airpods because in fact i'm recording
the video on my iphone which is located
about six feet away from me on a tripod
now the iphone is connected into my
computer because i have my computer open
beside my ipad
and plugged into my computer
is first of all a microphone
and second of all is a
cable that takes me back to my iphone
and then i use quicktime and i use a
program on quicktime to make sure that
i'm centered more or less centered
because i tend to be a bit sloppy in
whatever i do but
i got i can see on my computer screen
how i am centered what actually will
show up in the video so i have to get
that going now the audio from my iphone
because it's six feet away wouldn't be
very good so i have my microphone
plugged into my computer and i use
audacity to record
the
audio and then we merge the audio and
the video files in order to get
a good quality video and audio so we are
not at all dependent on the connection
that we have through zoom
because
although zoom and skype have improved
there can be interruptions and frozen
moments and you know in different audio
quality and so forth one other thing is
for whatever strange reason every time i
open audacity i get an error message so
i always have to go through the same
step of quitting audacity searching for
it with that microphone
magnifying glass to get it up again and
then the second time i get into audacity
it works so
just some background oh and i have three
different sets of lights here to improve
the light quality
so there's a whole setup process to do
these to tell my story and
how about it you're well i guess the the
interesting thing about that whole setup
you've got there is it didn't begin like
that did it something that's evolved
over the over the years and as
as
there's there's so many parallels
between this and other things in life
aren't they where you just start off
you know your very first video i believe
as a webcam
on your computer with you just sitting
on a chair and that was that same for me
um but then as we go we add more things
on so
my setup is
at the moment so we are talking on
zoom that's how we're doing it and right
now i'm looking at
the call itself into the laptop which
nobody can see but i can't record with
the laptop because the camera is no good
so what i do is i have my fancy dslr
camera which i use for my youtube videos
um set up over here above the screen up
here
so i'm looking at the camera right now
because that's
how we get a nice effect for the
audience who watches it later
but i can't see your face your face is
down here and i'm looking at the camera
up here
and then linked to my camera i have
an overhead mic which is up here
which is captured which is capturing my
voice
that's linked directly into the camera
i can see over here
what's coming up from the camera to make
sure that
it's still recording and i'm centered
and i also have two box lights up here
one back light and then four or five
different lights in the background um to
light it up and see if you won't be able
to see that right now because you're
just staring into your camera but when
you see the final result on youtube
right uh it will hopefully look quite
good yeah
i'm afraid that some of my viewers are
going to say why don't you get a set up
like ollie because his is much better
than yours so we'll see work it's it's
in any case we continue to evolve
and and and language learning continues
to evolve
um what do you think are some of the
major sort of changes that have taken
place say
which was the first sort of language
that you other than english you know
your first foreign language which was
the first one and and if you compare how
uh you know
the world of language learning today to
when you first started what have been
some of the main changes so my first
language was french and um i
remember
working in a cafe in london when i first
when i first heard french around me and
thought well that sounds fantastic let's
go and learn it and so on my way home i
would stop by the european bookshop
which was then in nourishing gloucester
road at the time it was in soho and i
would go back and the only way that i
knew
to learn french was with textbooks
because that's what we did at school and
so i would go down into the european
bookshop um
in soho and i would go down and browse
all of the french grammar books you had
the complete mailed which was
the perennial french book which was
there already at the time and then there
were the collins books the teach
yourself books i don't i don't remember
what they were
and i would simply
flick through the grammar books till i
found one that seemed more or less what
i might enjoy and then i would work
through it page by page
um
and
and that was pretty much it
now um
fast forward 20 years or so but
subsequently you learn spanish you
learned arabic you learned a whole bunch
of languages yeah and all of that was in
the kind of analog methods as well so i
i think because i was
i was kind of trained in that way i've
always found personally that
digitizing language learning
robs me of attention
which is for me is the most valuable
asset when it comes to learning anything
so i've always got been i've always be
been quite
i've always preferred you know pencil
and paper to anything else
the big things that have changed i mean
the major ways that i use technology now
would be for uh for example reading
reading japanese i would read digitally
always because it's just so much faster
to look up either the you know the read
the reading of
a kanji or the or the meaning of a kanji
um and then obviously i use the internet
to take language lessons
to connect with tutors
and
and just for general for general i mean
you know watch movies
all the regular stuff really but that's
about it i'm not a big one for apps i'm
a big fan of link i use link on a
regular basis
um but but i i very much i very much
use the internet to connect to native
speakers to read content and then
sometimes with a little bit of help
when it gets hard
right
uh interesting
i think it's true and i agree with you
that reading
on paper
uh is better than reading on a computer
uh but there are a few conditions there
it's better because you there are fewer
distractions and and you are basically
dealing with the words and they're not
shining at you and it's it's less
distracting
however i find that
in my own case
i have to be at a certain level in order
to be able to read on paper
uh so if i take an extreme example now
of course when i learned chinese there
were no you know computer
there was no digital text so it was all
paper but nowadays learning persian and
arabic i'm just not strong enough in
arabic i have your book by the way
arabic short stories
and i can read them but it's tough
because the pronunciation is not obvious
the words that i don't know i don't know
so if i can read it digitally i can hear
the text to speech i can look the word
up
i can see in some languages if i look
the word up say on link i can see a
conjugating dictionary i get a whole
bunch of additional information which i
find useful but my goal is to get to a
level where i can read comfortably
a conventional book and so even in terms
of say slavic languages it's easier for
me to read czech or polish simply
because the alphabet that we're more
used to is it's just that much easier
for us to read
even something like the cyrillic
alphabet which is really not that
difficult it's still just that little
bit more of a chore than reading in the
alphabet that you're most familiar with
uh
the other thing is
if i go back in history
the reason we started link is because i
had books at home in german and in
spanish and there was always
five ten words per page that i didn't
know and i got tired of looking them up
in the dictionary for getting them and
so even with those languages where let's
say that there's more than five percent
unknown words i prefer now even now to
read uh you know digitally
uh as my main means of acquiring these
words
but for relaxation even though there are
words i don't know i just
skip over them and i read them in a in a
traditional book and i will get there by
the way with your arabic shorts
i have no doubt that you will um it's
you know i think it's i always
i'm left with the impression that when
you have people such as yourself who
already know how they learn language is
best and they have their method that
they've perfected over many
many years and many languages um
there's a very
specific set of of conditions there and
we you know we kind of we know what we
like and we we find ways to make to make
that work we don't bend to the
technology we got to make the technology
bend to us as it as it were but i think
for most people
really the
i think this is
i think about it as a question of of
just peeling back layers of difficulty
one by one and i think this is where
technology
is interesting in the
how the development of technology is
interesting because because
i i don't really know so much about the
the app or the technology space because
because i just simply don't use it so
much myself but when you when it comes
to content and the kind of content that
people are making i i find that very
interesting and i think the fact that
people can create content now and
distribute it to a wide audience is very
important because it motivates them to
to to do so you know so i could think of
any
number of examples of content creators
on youtube
who are now making content on uh based
around comprehensible input for example
so this is something that we are
obviously big proponents of and it's one
of of many different approaches to
language learning but you've got people
who are making entire videos teaching
french or japanese or spanish with
comprehensible input and they're using
they're using objects realia as as it's
known they're using whiteboards computer
screen they're making these
everything that they're doing is making
the language more access slightly more
accessible one layer at a time
and that's i think where technology for
me seems to be really exciting is the
evolution of these content platforms so
that someone can be a language creator
on youtube and then earn
a living from doing that which means
they can then make more and recently
we've seen this huge proliferation in
the
amounts of useful content that's being
created and it's out there for free um
and that's a that's kind of a
hidden
a hidden way in which technology is is
driving things forward you know not so
much at the in the in the app or
software but into the enabling of people
who are just natural teachers to to
teach
uh abs i i agree and if we go into the
sort of language books section of any
bookstore whether it be in tokyo or
london
there's a limited number of books that
can be there even if there's 10
different editions you know living
language and i don't know
you know any number of it's not going to
be a hundred
it can only be the store can't possibly
stock a hundred different
books for learning these different
languages but there's no limit on the
internet
there's no limit on youtube
and so different people have different
ideas of how they can help people learn
and they just put them up and then you
get feedback as well the difficulty is
actually finding them you get that and
you get instant feedback so you can you
can iterate very quickly but when it
comes to you know books for example we
recently just published a book of um
japanese
short stories and it's taken us
i think two well from when i first
raised it published about three years to
get it out
um
you know the length of time is
preposterous really to get to take a
book from i mean it was probably only a
year a year and a half or a year to a
year and a half of actual work but but
the when you think about
that we have one we basically have one
shot to get it right we spend a lot of
time up front and then we put it out and
we hope that it does well we hope that
it's useful for people um but if i were
to do say instead of writing a book on
of japanese stories instead to say i'm
going to make a youtube channel about
japanese in that year and a half i could
be so much more attuned to what the
content that people actually like having
listened to them read their comments
tried things out so it's an incredibly
powerful um dynamic it's all it's almost
like the dynamic between a teacher and a
student you know that that ins the
feedback loop that we get right and
feed like loop is important and the
other thing is just the the cost of
getting it out there if you spend three
years getting your japanese
storybook out there you'd be
hard-pressed to get 10 000 people to buy
that book i don't know what your numbers
are but
my experience would tell me that that
would be a large number
you can get a hundred thousand views
of a video on youtube yeah
and that you can make more and more
videos and so you you know the the the
economies of scale are so much better
um
one thing with youtube i'm a great
believer in youtube by the way
incidentally as you know at link we have
a
browser extension where we can
automatically import youtube videos with
the
subtitles the captions and that then oh
i didn't know you could do that well
that's fantastic a lot oh yeah i just
click on it
uh you know and i'm using things like i
don't know there's this
and that's another thing you know
content creation doesn't just have to be
people like yourself or fonte francio
tantique or other people who are
creating great content
uh there's a jordanian
television you know i follow this
jordanian television station in 17
arabic and there's also this sort of
somewhat like you know the flintstones
type of cartoon
in jordanian arabic which has
you know subtitles in both english and
arabic
and so i can import that into link the
arabic becomes the text but i can
actually actually follow the video and
see the english subtitles and then go
through the text and of course the text
is divided it's timestamped so it's
sentence by sentence i can go through
listening to the cartoon characters say
whatever they have to say
word by you know sentence by sentence
but then i can also watch their cartoon
to get over and the cartoon is three
minutes long so this is content this is
tremendous learning content so there is
no limit to i mean i could think of more
examples like that both netflix and
youtube where you can bring these things
in to
link and use them as learning material
in fact a lot of the stuff that we're
now that i'm now seeing in both persian
and arabic
are links to
this kind of content so it's not in our
library
so it's not that i'm distributing it to
our members but there is a link there
that enables the member to go there and
then download it into their account so
they are able to access all of this uh
content
so i mean yeah it's exploding
what i have a question sure
uh
grammar
i was thinking about grammar the other
day
and i often feel that people are sort of
taught grammar before they have
enough experience with the language so
that the grammar becomes it's difficult
to understand what the point is uh
difficult to remember these rules
you know much less apply them however i
find that when i'm at a certain level in
the language i do want to get closer to
the grammar i've had enough experience
with the language that i understand the
points they're trying to make i've
actually experienced it you know
and i feel that there is a lack of
grammar texts in the target language
not for beginners because beginners
wouldn't be able to
follow the grammatical explanation in
the language that they're trying to
learn
but when you're at a kind of almost like
a b1 plus almost b2 level
if there was
a course
in the target language
about the grammar
not too long audio text text can be
imported into link audio i can listen to
in my car
i think that would be a great resource
have you ever given that so that those
are not stories the stories are the key
i agree with you
uh because the stories is sort of the
enjoyment part of getting the language
into you getting the brain used to the
language but we all want to be better we
want to be more accurate in our use of
the language but if we could make the
grammar learning also meaningful input
in the target language i think that
would be easy sure well i mean we do we
do almost exactly that um at story
learning actually so what we have and
you can tell me with whether this is um
whether i'm describing what you have in
mind here but so we we run these monthly
challenges so we have um
uh
they are 30 days long basically so what
we do is we will take a grammar point in
a language a tricky grammar point so say
for example the difference between the
past tenses in spanish which is a
perennial problem and so we will write a
story there's 30 in 30 chapters 30 days
long based on
which focuses uh heavily on that grammar
point and so the idea is that um
in this case you know the two past
tenses and so the idea is that you spend
30 days on a daily basis reading content
that features that grammar point very
heavily um and then through by
by force our input and repetition and
frequency um you end up just kind of
developing that natural that natural
feel
and we find it works really well because
because as you said
the the barrier there really is it's
just it's it's getting used to the way
that that grammar works and it's
developing i mean i can't tell you how
often
how often
i've had this experience of um
you know
knowing
thinking that i know the grammar of a
language fairly well
but never quite being able to use it in
speech and then going off and spending a
year reading in the language and coming
back and suddenly finding without having
done any extra study that the grammar
just rolls off my tongue naturally you
know more naturally than before it's
simply a question of um
of exposure over time frequency and
exposure i mean
there really is like like no i agree no
other element to it but it can't that
can be quite a tough a tough pill to
swallow for um
for someone who's coming at it
new because it it's it's not it's never
the case that you can kind of chart
your
development or your progress against
days or hours of study you know you just
have to
you just have to you know just dive in
surround yourself by it and then just
trust that that you will then develop
the knowledge as as you go right
yeah i mean uh
i think the brain we underestimate the
brain the brain has the capacity to
establish rules create patterns
connections
and so all
after a year of reading you're going to
naturally use the language more
correctly
but some things you won't notice and so
we all know people who have lived in
britain or canada for 30 years and still
make the same fundamental mistakes in
english that reflect their native
language
uh but
they're still getting more or they've
reached a certain level at least where
much of what they say in english is
grammatically correct
so the brain will form patterns
and to that extent i agree with you that
lots of listening reading is going to
help the brain form patterns that are
increasingly correct but there are
things that we don't notice
and i think when we start into the
language some sort of overall
description of how the language works in
english is kind of helpful as long as we
don't try to remember any of it because
we can't
but it kind of helps us although certain
things are immediately obvious the verb
comes at the end you almost don't need
to be
told that you'll figure that out pretty
quickly